dans un menu
[Musique]
une fête nationale sous le signe de la
rupture en catalogne en pleine crise
sanitaire l'occasion de relancer la
mobilisation des indépendantistes sous
tension depuis des semaines le mois
dernier quart laisse plus demond a rendu
sa carte du parti nationaliste catalan
pour créer un
moment des célébrations a minima dans
une région fortement touchée par la
pandémie
[Musique]
à la veille du grand retour des gilets
jaunes sur les ronds points demain en
france l'une des figures relaxé par la
cour d'appel de paris
eric drew était poursuivi pour
l'organisation de deux manifestations
non déclarées
il avait été condamné en première
instance à 2000 euros damende les
antilles masquer les patrons de
discothèques et des chauffeurs de vtc
devraient se joindre aux manifestations
demain alors que la france a dépassé le
seuil d alerte de la circulation du
virus l'intervention du premier ministre
depuis matignon aujourd'hui tout
confiant que l'intensité du virus n'a
pas baissé a averti jean castex exécutif
qui s'est réuni en conseil de défense et
de sécurité ce matin n'est pas de
nouvelles mesures de restriction
annoncées
la france qui a atteint le nombre record
de près de 10000 contamination détecter
ces 24 heures
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi la grande
fête nationale de la catalogne mise en
sourdine second septembre à cause de la
crise sanitaire un événement qui
rassemble en temps normal des dizaines
de milliers de personnes dans les rues
l'occasion aussi pour les enfants
d'indépendantistes de se faire entendre
sauf que cette année les manifestations
sont restreintes à cause de la pandémie
qui a durement éprouvé cette région de
l'espagne et pour en parler nous sommes
avec ignace y forte unie président de
l'assemblée nationale catalane en france
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir une assise forte unie merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france pour les
indépendantistes cette situation
sanitaire ne compromette elle pas leur
chance de s'unir
eh bien je pense que ce n'est pas
tellement la situation la crise
sanitaire parce que de tous dans tout
état de cause malgré la crise sanitaire
on a organisé aujourd'hui dans la
journée dans pratiquement toutes les
villes de catalogne 137 actes en
respectant de tous les toutous les
distances et les impératifs duo covit 19
mai
ces actions ont été faites et ces
manifestations étaient le fait dans le
cadre de l'unité
bien entendu il est normal dans tout
mouvement qu'il y ait des divergences
stratégiques
c'est normal mais il ya quand même le
point commun qui rassemble tout le monde
c'est celui de la création et la
fondation d'une république catalan et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le débat
et les discussions pour l'unité de la
catalogne vont bon train malgré tout
vous parler maintenant de l'unité de la
catalogne est ce qu il est toujours
question d'indépendance foncé il y à une
guerre des chefs en tout cas entre les
tôles en les tenant d'une ligne dure et
les autres il ya louis l'indépendance
départ c'est le point commun tous le
mouvement indépendantiste
c'est à dire que tout le monde est
d'accord sur la république catalan ce
qui ce qui change c'est justement les
questions stratégiques
il y a des une partie de
l'indépendantisme qui pensent qu'il faut
aller vers une confrontation
intelligente comme l'a précisé le
président en exil à bruxelles qui est
député européen également en expliquant
cette cette confrontation intelligente
dans la mesure où l'état espagne on ne
croient pas au dialogue puisque l'état
espagnol ne ve pas de dialogue
et d'ailleurs il a été impossible
jusqu'à l'heure actuelle de fixer un
ordre du jour et le gouvernement
espagnol refuse de se mettre d'accord
sur un ordre du jour une partie de
l'indépendantisme pense qu'il faut être
plus plan dans le processus et
convaincre davantage de des catalans
pour pour pouvoir voter et organiser le
référendum
donc il ya ces divergences stratégiques
mais ce ne sont pas des différences de
fond n'est sur le ni sur les objectifs
sur ce plan là il ya une unité totale de
tout le mouvement indépendantiste
donc les mêmes objectifs les
et moyens d'y parvenir peut-être d'y
faire on sait que carl f puis je demande
donc y est vous l'avez dit en belgique
actuellement veut former un nouveau
mouvement c'est possible selon vous oui
absolument
c'est à dire qu'il y a il faut aussi
l'explication de ce nouveau mouvement
provient en grande partie de l'histoire
des partis politiques récents en
catalogne il est il est vrai aussi que
damon si bien ils étaient 7 et 1 le
candidat du parti des démocrates de
catalogne
il est vrai aussi qu'aujourd'hui
rassemble d'un mouvement beaucoup plus
large que pour damon rassemble des gens
de gauche rassemble des gens de centre
gauche des gens de centre droit et que
par conséquent il est normal qu'il y ait
des tensions et qu' une partie de ce
parti n'est pas vous souhaitez élargir
ce large mouvement qu'il a créé ou du
nom de ensemble pour la catalogne et que
par conséquent on sait je pense que il a
eu l'air raison quelque part puisque
dans ce sens projet 20 dans le sens de
l'unité 1 de l'indépendantisme une
nouvelle donne dans ce contexte
sanitaire c'est la formation d'un
gouvernement de coalition en espagne
avec pedro sanchez toujours à sa tête
mais fragilisée oui c'est un 71.5 chessa
son gouvernement socialiste en alliance
avec podemos a toujours a de tout temps
depuis le début n'a pas la majorité
absolue au parlement espagnol
ce qui l oblige à rechercher des
alliances il a été d'ailleurs été élu
grâce au soutien des indépendantistes
catalans faute de quoi ils nord il ne
leur pas été mais en même temps c'est
quelqu'un en qui on ne peut pas faire
trop confiance puisque il essaye surtout
de de convaincre les indépendantistes
catalans qu'il est prêt au dialogue etc
mais en fait son sol son sol but est
tout simplement d'obtenir une certaine
stabilité politique
mais dès qu'il a obtenu six tableaux
cette stabilité politique commirent la
recherche à l'heure actuelle
pour le vote du budget de 2021 une fois
il a il obtient cette stabilité
politique du moins pendant pendant
quelque temps automatiquement
il est il ne remet en cause le dialogue
et il est très extrêmement difficiles
ont la plupart du mouvement
indépendantiste catalan ne croient pas
au dialogue parce que nous pensons que
l'espagne ne veut pas dialoguer parce
que en outre dialogue sans négociation
n'a aucun sens qu'est ce que ça veut
dire dialoguer en discussions du café de
commerce sinon ce n'est pas ça une
négociation l'année où ça ça veut dire
un ordre du jour avec des points
essentiels et nos points essentiels
c'est d'une part la reconnaissance du
droit à l'autodétermination
l'organisation d'un référendum et
l'aministie de tous les prisonniers
politiques
et bien entendu l'arrêt de la répression
qui continue de plus belle bien entendu
aujourd'hui on n'arrête plus les hommes
politiques de premier plan quand ils
sont déjà en prison mais on a on arrête
des des hommes politiques et des hauts
fonctionnaires de deuxième plan et
notamment aussi ils sont entrés ya il ya
un procès d'inégibilité contre le
président actuel de la catalogne
parce que tout simplement ils avaient
mis une pancarte sur la façade du siège
du gouvernement en demandant la liberté
des prisonniers politiques
or il a été poursuivi et il va passer en
devant la cour suprême de madrid qui au
demeurant ces teintes à un tribunal qui
fait la pluie et le beau temps en
matière politique en espagne ce qui
n'est pas normal
il ya en cause de ça il ya plus de
séparation de pouvoir en espagne
donc le président actuel de la de la
catalogne risque d'être in et déclaré
inéligible
le 17 septembre ce qui va l'obliger à
démissionner de ses fonctions et de sans
doute de poids de convoquer de nouvelles
élections au parlement de catalogne ce
qui est à notre avis intolérable dans la
mesure où que pour une simple pancarte
en déclare inéligibles le président de
la catalogne nous paraît une
intromission intolérable de la justice
espagnole
la politique très courts et nyassi
fortune isf qui a eu un impact de la
crise sanitaire on sait que la catalogne
a été durement éprouvée l'espagne
d'ailleurs en général est ce que ça me
ça fragilise le pouvoir à madrid et la
perception des catalans envers le
pouvoir central je pense que il faut
tenir compte aussi c'est que la
situation de l'espagne et est
extrêmement complexe à l'heure actuelle
le problème catalan lesquin une facette
dix ans de cette crise institutionnelle
que l'on vit en espagne notamment du
fait qu' il y à vous l'avez vu une crise
de la monarchie il y à une crise du
système politique à une crise économique
aggravée par le par la pandémie et il ya
une crise territoriales très fortes
notamment le fait que il ya aussi une
corruption qui n'a pas l'air de vouloir
être résorbé que la corruption continue
de plus belle en dans toute l'espagne
donc tout ce tout ceci ce sont des
éléments de fragilisation du
gouvernement qu'il soit socialiste ou
une autre couleur politique
la situation en espagne est fragile ce
qui est en même temps pardon merci
beaucoup il n'y est si forte unie merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france à la veille du grand retour des
gis les jaunes sur les ronds points
demain france l'une des figures du
mouvement été relaxé par la cour d'appel
de paris aujourd'hui les antilles
masquer les patrons de discothèques ou
des chauffeurs de vtc devraient se
joindre aux manifestations demain vous
découvrez ici à l'image les différents
parcours des cortèges dans la capitale
eric drew a été poursuivi pour
l'organisation de deux manifestations
non déclarées il avait été condamné à
2000 euros d'amendé en première instance
voyez les détails sur place de notre
reporter katia technique c'est une
victoire pour eric drew et le délibéré
du jugement en appel lui est totalement
favorable
le président de la cour d'appel a
prononcé l'annulation de
l'interpellation pour les faits du 22
décembre 2010 huit annulations de renvoi
des fins de la poursuite la condamnation
est donc annulée et pour les fêtes
2 janvier 2019 eh bien c'est la relaxe
pure et simple
pour cette figure des gilet jaune et
rigoureux et donc totalement blanchi il
ya eu un procès d'appel en juin et son
avocat qui optent larrat avait plaidé le
fait que son client n'avait pas pu
organiser de manifestations
en effet le mouvement des gilet jaune et
horizontal il n'y a pas de chef de
leader donc eric drew et ne pouvait pas
en être un d'ailleurs les décisions sont
prises collectivement au sein de ce
mouvement
et puis pour les faits de janvier est
bien eric drew était venu avec 5 ou 6 g
les jaunes seulement il ne s'agissait
pas à proprement parler d'un
rassemblement alors le conseil et d'eric
drouet qui l'obs lara s'est montré très
soulagé et satisfait de ce verdict qui
pourrait selon lui peut-être faire
jurisprudence je vous propose de
l'écouter que c'est la fin d'un combat
le temps a joué pour nous ce dossier qui
avait été plaidé longuement au mois de
juin dans des conditions plus sereines
c'est justice eric drôle mais c'est
aussi justice pour tous et j'ai des
jeunes qui manifestent pacifiquement
parce que c'est ça qu'on disait depuis
le départ la c2 affaire où eric d'euros
et avait été condamnée mis en garde à
vue pour une bougie place de la concorde
et l'autre où étaient simples
manifestants comme tous les autres sans
aucun acte de violence ait un peu de
justice pour lui mais aussi pour le
mouvement des gilets jaunes donc par
définition ça veut dire qu'ils ont
compris ce qu'on dit depuis début de
façon simple et démontrer c'est que les
gilets jaunes n'y a pas de chef
les figures n'y a pas de chef et que
c'est pas le le mouvement classique où
il y avait quelqu'un qui va faire un
appel c'est plus délicat que c'est
manifestement la cour l'a entendu et
j'en suis très heureux qu'aujourd'hui
cette justice a été rendue ici à la cour
d'appel de paris
c'est une grande satisfaction je pense
que en tout cas même au niveau du
symbole c'est quand même très fort
effectivement la veille de ce genre de
cette journée de rassemblement
voilà je lui dirai qu'il peut y aller
tranquillement puis c'est une belle
image aussi
en tout cas juste ici entendu certaines
choses c'est que le droit est aussi du
côté du jury jeune eric drew et ne s'est
pas présenté à l'audience sa présence
n'était pas obligatoire et puis il faut
dire que ces derniers mois elle s'est un
peu mis en retrait pour se concentrer
sur son activité professionnelle et
retrouver un peu de calme nous a dit son
avocat alors la question que tout le
monde se pose sera-t-il en revanche
présents pour les manifestations du 12
septembre
et bien selon son avocat c'est fort
possible hier c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a annoncé déposé plainte
contre jérôme rodriguez une autre figure
du mouvement des gilet jaune gérald
darmanin qui a présenté aujourd'hui sa
nouvelle doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
il a annoncé dès demain l'utilisation
d'une nouvelle grenade de
désencerclement ainsi qu'à un usage
encadré du fameux lanceurs de balles de
défense chaque tir devra être soumis à
l'accord d'un superviseur écrit m
il nous faut aussi diminuer le nombre de
violences et de blessés lors des
manifestations
qu'il s'agisse de ceux qui touchent les
forces de l'ordre où les citoyens qui
sont là la doctrine ou les conditions
d'emploi de certains matériels vont
évoluer
je pense notamment à l'usagé ulb des qui
sera dès demain
encadré obligatoirement assorti d'un
superviseur pour mieux évaluer la
situation d'ensemble est désigné
l'objectif je pense également à
l'utilisation des grenades gmd qui sera
retirée du service suivant les
recommandations du dgpn et du dggn et
remplacé dès demain par un nouveau
modèle offrant moins de projection
auteurs en effet dès ce samedi
toujours en france l'allocution de jean
castex le premier ministre depuis
matignon aujourd'hui avec une
préoccupation affichée par le chef du
gouvernement une augmentation du nombre
de personnes hospitalisées
voilà pour le constat il n'ya pas de
ligne maginot a averti jean castex
la france a enregistré près de dix mille
nouvelles contaminations ces dernières
24 heures le virus est bien là mais il
ne faut pas entrer dans une nouvelle
logique de confinement voyez les
précisions sur place à matignon de notre
reporter lille à faa'a musou finalement
très peu de mesures annoncées par jean
castex lors de cette allocution qui a
été très courte qui a duré à peu près
huit minutes alors que tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge et que la
pression sanitaire s'accentue ce matin
même jean-françois de free si le
président du conseil scientifique
appelait le gouvernement à prendre des
décisions difficiles mais nécessaires il
semblerait qu'il n'a pas été entendu par
l'exécutif qui souhaitait pourtant
provoqué un électrochoc auprès des
français pour leur montrer que
finalement la lutte contre la
propagation du virus est de la
responsabilité de tous alors dans son
allocution jean castex a reconnu un que
le pourcentage de cas positifs ne
cessait d'augmenter à ce jour on est à
quarante deux départements classés en
zone rouge mais le gouvernement ne
prévoit pas pour autant de mettre en
place un confinement généralisée il
s'agirait plutôt d'accentuer les efforts
sur le dépistage et renforcer les
équipes de l'assurance maladie pour
permettre de remonter plus rapidement
les fameuses chaîne de contamination
écoutez premier ministre nous veillerons
là où il y a des besoins et notamment
dans les grandes villes a installé des
tentes de dépistage qui leur seront
également dédiés pour les personnes
testées positives et celles avec
lesquelles elles ont été en contact
le conseil de défense a pris deux
décisions pour améliorer la surveillance
épidémiologique première décision 2000
recrutements supplémentaires
seront effectués au sein de l'assurance
maladie et des agences régionales de
santé pour réaliser ce qu'on appelle le
traçage deuxième décision sur
proposition du conseil scientifique la
durée d'isolement sera ramené à 7 jours
c'est à dire la durée pendant laquelle
il y à un véritable risque de contagion
il est primordial que chacun respecte
strictement cette durée d'isolement ce
qui donnera lieu à des contrôles alors
que la menace d'une deuxième vague se
profile l'enjeu est capital pour
l'exécutif
il s'agit d'éviter à tout prix un
nouveau confinement qui aurait des
conséquences désastreuses sur l'économie
en grèce après avoir incendié le conte
de morat ya des milliers de migrants
sans abri ont manifesté aujourd'hui pour
exiger leur départ de l'île de lesbos la
grèce qui appelle de son côté l'union
européenne à agir concrètement
david khalfa
de la colère mais surtout un appel au
secours pour ces milliers de migrants
demandeurs d'asile sans abri a bloqué à
lesbos
ils réclament leur départ de cette île
grecque où des incendies gigantesques
ont détruit ces derniers jours le camps
sordides de morgat le plus grand
d'europe
j'ai cinq enfants et nous vivons ici
dans de mauvaises conditions parce que
la nuit il fait très froid et nous
n'avons rien tous mes biens ont brûlé
j'ai très peur j'ai très peur ici à
moria je fais des crises d angoisse tout
le temps je suis dans une mauvaise
situation et mes enfants sont tous petit
et ils sont souvent malades nous avons
besoin dead des incendies qui ont
détruit la jungle de moria où habitait
près de 12000 700 personnes soit quatre
fois plus que sa capacité initiale
les flammes ont laissés dans la rue de
nombreuses familles dont 4000 enfants
face à ce drame la grèce a lancé un cri
d'alarmé l'union européenne pour venir
en aide à ces personnes et notamment aux
mineurs est dix pays de l'union
européenne vont donc accueillir quelques
400 migrants mineurs non accompagnés à
la suite des discussions entre les états
membres de l'union européenne
dix états participeront avec nous à la
relocalisation des mineurs non
accompagnés
d'après ce que je sais nous sommes
toujours en discussion avec d'autres
états membres
fantine fillon de la part de ces 400
mineurs seront accueillis par la france
et l'allemagne
selon nos informations l'allemagne et la
france accueilleront chacune entre 100
et 150 mineurs windows phone 7 un drame
qui relance le débat sur l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile en europe
passer des paroles aux actes voilà
l'exhortation du gouvernement grec à ses
partenaires européens lors du sommet
euro med 7 qui se tient encore cette
semaine pour répondre à la crise
migratoire
la commission européenne doit présenter
à la fin du mois une proposition très
attendu et plusieurs fois repoussé d'un
nouveau pacte sur l'immigration et
l'asile
le troisième point de la proposition
serait un système de solidarité
permanente et efficace pour assumer les
responsabilités en matière d'asile non
seulement entre les quelques états
membres à l'entrée de l'union européenne
où les quelques états membres comme
l'allemagne qui font exception
nous avons besoin d'une véritable
solidarité dans notre politique
migratoire
[Musique]
pour sa part le gouvernement grec peine
à se courir ces migrants et appelle les
autorités locales à trouver une solution
rapide pour héberger les sans abri
la protection civile grecque qui a
déclaré l'état d'urgence pour quatre
mois à lesbos forte de 85 mille
habitants et principale porte d'entrée
des migrants en grèce en raison de sa
proximité avec la turquie
l approche des élections présidentielles
aux états unis ces nouvelles accusations
de cyber attaques russes et chinoises et
manon des géants du web américain hier
un ukrainien considéré comme un agent de
la russie a été sanctionné pour avoir
tenté je cite de discréditer le candidat
démocrate joe weiden des montages qui
aurait même été relayée par donald trump
lui même
voyez ce qu'en dit la porte parole du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
moscou qui va demander à berlin de
pouvoir interroger l'opposant russe
alexeï navalni actuellement hospitalisé
dans la capitale allemande
le ministère russe de l'intérieur veut
envoyer ses propres enquêteurs pour
assister au travail des enquêteurs
allemands et poser des questions
supplémentaires alexeï navalni
l'allemagne qui affirme que l'opposant
russe a été empoisonnée accusations
toujours rejeté avec véhémence par les
autorités russes soyez les précisions à
moscou de notre correspondante verhaeghe
hoffman
une journée riche en déclarations au
sujet de la sphère navalni d'abord les
questions de l'empoisonnement présumé a
été au coeur des discussions au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu s'était le
représentant permanent russe auprès de
l'onu va si les libyens et qui a réagi
en qualifiant la sphère navale n'aidant
jeu déloyal
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
son intervention cet incident dans son
ensemble ne fait que soulever des
questions concernant le jeu déloyal qui
est en train d'être menée nous avons
entendu qu'elle déclaration en suivi et
quelles mesures ont été évoqués des
bacchus est proposé cela soulève la
question rhétorique inévitable que poser
les latins dans des situations pareilles
cui bono y ce fait qui twitte prodest
c'est celui à qui cela profite qu il a
fait
si vous exigez des explications
présentées les faits et nous comparons
nos informations pour de fax hommes de
paiement
pourquoi doit-on croire des allégations
qui ne sont pas corroborées par des
preuves
même si selon vous c'est hors de tout
doute raisonnable
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov à son tour
évoqué la sphère de l'empoisonnement
présumé et les tensions diplomatiques
autour de la sphère lors de sa
conférence de presse avec son homologue
chinois je vous propose d'écouter encore
un extrait
il a été annoncé que la partie allemande
avait envoyé une lettre officielle à
l'organisation pour l'interdiction des
armes chimiques et qu'elle a l'exhorté
le secrétariat de l'oit est assez à
prendre certaines mesures
nous avons pris connaissance de cette
lettre
elle ne dit qu'une chose selon les
experts allemands
il s'agit d'un empoisonnement à l'aide
du prétendu novice choc
il n'y a eu aucune autre communication
entre berlin et le jass et nous avons
bien sûr intérêt à obtenir les
informations qui pour une raison
quelconque sont soigneusement cachée par
la partie allemande au moins via les
hoyas et si on ne peut pas les obtenir
directement notre représentant permanent
s'est adressé à maintes reprises aux
dirigeants du secrétariat de lolya c'est
chaque fois y compris hier soir on lui a
dit qu aucune autre communication
contenant des faits sur lesquels se
fondent des accusations d'empoisonnement
n'avait été transmise à loyat si le
département des transports du ministère
russe de l'intérieur en charge des
vérifications préliminaires concernant
l'hospitalisation de navalni va demander
que des enquêteurs russes puissent
assister aux activités des enquêteurs
allemands avec l'opposant russe et lui
poser quelques questions supplémentaires
selon les dernières informations alexeï
navalni a été sorti du coma artificiel
le 7 septembre
au proche orient une normalisation des
relations entre israël et bahreïn après
les émirats arabes unis à la mi août
l'annoncé a été faite ce soir par donald
trump sur les réseaux sociaux
mardi prochain le président américain va
recevoir une cérémonie officielle le
premier ministre israélien sera présent
ainsi que le chef de la diplomatie
émirati et le prince héritier de bahreïn
voyait la réaction pour commencer du
premier ministre israélien
mieux grâce le bosseur citoyens d'israël
je suis heureux de vous informer que
nous allons conclure un autre accord de
paix avec un autre pays arabe avec le
bahreïn
ils s'ajoutent à l'accord de paix
historique avec les émirats arabes unis
nous a fallu 26 ans pour conclure le
deuxième accord de paix avec un pays
arabe
il y en aura d'autres c'est une nouvelle
ère de paix nous avons investi dans la
paix pendant de nombreuses années et
maintenant la paix va investir en nous
et nous conduire à des investissements
très importants dans l'économie
israélienne
tous ces accords sont le fruit d'un
travail acharné en coulisses pendant des
années mais ils ont été réalisés grâce à
l'aide importante de notre ami le
président américain donald trump et je
voudrais le remercier lui son équipe
pour cette aide importante
une nouvelle ère la paix pour la paix
sera jouée d'un crâne un genou à genou
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans 30
minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
en pleine crise du couronne virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différents